i just feel that we're grown-ups now i
just got married she just got engaged
sounds like paris hilton and lindsay
lohan have buried the hatchet after
years of feuding we're not like in high
school like i was it was i think it was
just very immature
and now everything is all good that's
paris sharing an update about her and
lilo on watch what happens live with
andy cohen i saw that she got engaged
when i was on my honeymoon and i just
said congratulations and then and that
and that broke the ice lindsay got
engaged to financier bader shamas in
late november just weeks after paris
tied the knot with her now hubby carter
rheem i've never
met a man like this in my life i've
never been with someone who loves and
supports me so much and lifts me up and
isn't intimidated and
is just like my best friend and my
prince charming all rolled into one
fieris first reacted to her one-time
pals happy news on her podcast i know
that we've had our differences in the
past
but i just wanted to say congratulations
to her and that i am genuinely very
happy for her the reality star even went
on to reference the holy trinity aka
herself lindsay and britney spears
after this iconic photo from 2006 made
the rounds online again as fans
celebrated the growth of the trio in
2022. it just makes me so happy to see
you know
15 years later
i got married
brittany got her freedom back and
engaged and then lindsay just got
engaged so i love seeing just how
different our lives are now and just how
much that we've all grown up
and just having love in our lives paris
and lindsay first bonded in the early
2000s frequently partying and hitting
the club scene together but eventually
their friendship soured and their feud
played out publicly in the tabloids
paris you've recently said that you
never want lindsay lohan's name spoken
in the same sentence as yours paris made
many disparaging comments about lindsay
in the past even as recently as 2019 on
watch what happens live say three nice
things about lindsay lohan
she's
beyond
okay that's fun that's that's a pretty
nice one to say that she's beyond lame
and embarrassing
okay the reality star immediately
regretted the harsh comments though
revealing on andy cohn's radio show the
next day that she just couldn't think of
anything nice to say at that moment
luckily that moment has passed i just
feel that we're grown-ups now i just got
married she just got engaged oh great
we're not like in high school like
it was i think it was just very immature
well newlywed paris is all about that
love here's what she told et about her
and carter's one-of-a-kind romance
carter and i have been friends for 15
years and as soon as we actually had our
first kiss about a year and a half ago i
just had this spark with him and i knew
he was the one
[Music]